on today's show we talked to a mom whose
15 year old son is stealing from family
members and she doesn't know what to do
we talked to a new dad who has adopted
kids
who are adopted embryos and he wants to
know when to tell him and we talk about
counseling what it is what it's not and
how to find a therapist stay tuned
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john delony show
glad you're here taking your calls on
on your relationships on your mental
health on parenting on whatever's going
on in your life
and in your world
[Music]
so normally this is when i make a joke
or i have some
funny things or some serious things or i
don't know
talk about something positive and
there's no no secret here you can hear
my voice it's been a hard uh hard few
days
and by the time you get this
we end up shooting these shows a couple
weeks ahead of of themselves i guess and
so
um this show you'll get in a few weeks
and um but this weekend man we lost a
loss lost delight lost to a buddy named
mark rogers
in a small town called abilene texas
man one of the most extraordinary men
i've ever met
in fact most most people outside my wife
and a few friends don't know this i it
was the first podcast i ever did in my
life i refused to be on the internet
and he had a show with his buddy
um called simply human and he's the
first guy
that talked to me about man wellness is
a much
bigger picture than you know trying to
do a marathon or trying to eat
keto or whatever and one of the funniest
guys
i've ever ever met man i was jealous of
him in so many ways super good looking
guy
he married one of my an old friend of
mine and together they had three
remarkable little girls
and he died suddenly this weekend in a
one in a million car wreck
senseless heartbreaking and
you know we talk a lot you guys hear me
answer other people's calls all the time
on this show
always talking to other people about
their challenges and there's just a
level of
dis ingenuousness is that the right word
i gotta be honest right and um
this is one of those days that i'm
hurting and one of those days it works
hard one of those days that um it's hard
to get out of bed
and those days that i hug my kids extra
tight and
you lose somebody like that there's just
there's just a few people on the planet
that were born
flashlights for other people to follow
he was the president of
big brothers big sisters in his
community ran a non-profit in his free
time with his wife
and um was just the dad of the century
man
and so to my brother mark we miss you
and all those folks
the thousands of young kids that you've
touched through
young life through big brothers big
sisters just by being the guy that was
funny and silly and
brought joy into other into dark places
man
um to that community it's going to be
more than your loss for years and years
and years
and the rogers family the barker family
those folks who are just going to be in
a lot of hurt
but you know that we're thinking about
you praying for you and um
i'm human too man and i'm i'm struggling
to get through this one this one was
extra extra extra hard
um not because we were super close we
didn't talk to each other man
we didn't talk that often but he had an
impact on me that was pretty significant
and he
um impacted a lot of people on a daily
basis so
um be thinking about you guys if you're
listening to this just so you know
we're people too man and we're we
struggle like everybody and we reach out
to our friends
and i've got a great group of friends
who've we've been communicating and
talking and
um even shared some heartbreak with my
old man old man
and mark were close too so those hard
things man and you get up you go to work
and then you make sure you surround
yourself with people who are going to
walk alongside you during hard times and
um and then we will continue to put good
into the world and
do what we can to make meaning on the
back end of this but um just want to
just be honest and share with everybody
you can hear my voice and
my normal like is just not there today
man
and then i can fake it and lie to
everybody and that's just that's not
it's not the show we're gonna do and
that's not the person i am so
we're glad that you're here thank you
for letting me talk about one of the
best men i've ever met mark rogers and
um let's let's go straight to the phones
today let's talk to
crystal in palmer alaska crystal what's
going on
hey what's good how are you doing i'm
good how are you
i'm good fantastic so what's going on
how can i help
yeah so i have a 15 year old son who
often steals from us and his younger
siblings
and i'm just looking for advice on how
to stop that behavior
all right so tell me what that looks
like
um it's kind of been a long-term thing
but the latest thing that happened
is that um my younger
children's tithing money went missing it
was over a hundred dollars
he denied it so i backed him up and then
i was cleaning his room a couple weeks
later and i found
the empty envelope yeah
yeah so what happened next
so um my husband works out of town so i
was kind of just
gonna let him deal with it um but
i i basically ended up telling him i had
found them
found it um he denied
taking the bigger chunk of money and
said at first that he just took the
daughter
my daughter's money which was ten
dollars but then i showed him
that i had the envelope so he didn't
take any personal responsibility
and then i don't know if it was right
thing to do or not but we basically
made them pay back him he paid them back
double so that they could pay their
tithing and then
so he had to come up with 200 bucks yeah
where did he get the other 100 bucks he
works okay so he has money the reason we
kind of doubled it was because
we've had him pay us back for things
that he's taken before and then
i kind of feel like in his mind it's
like he bought it ah
okay versus like i took something that i
shouldn't have taken
does that make sense you said this has
been happening for a long time when did
he start stealing from you guys
um i mean
i mean i'm sure he didn't do it when
he's a toddler but i basically remember
this happening his entire life
we're always finding our things in his
room he always takes
things from us and takes them apart
and he doesn't see anything wrong with
that
so what
so the question i always ask in this
situation is
based on one one sentiment is that
behavior is a language
so if with with that in mind
if you you know your son better than
anybody what is your
son trying to tell the people in his in
his
ecosystem in his world what's he trying
to tell him
um things don't matter he wants
desperately to be seen there is
tension among parents and he's trying to
say hey me look over here
the rules don't matter and there's
almost a pathology he doesn't understand
consequences um
what is there's chaos in the home and
that he's making sense of
chaos by grabbing what he like what is
what is his behavior
what is he trying to tell people
um the only thing i can think of is that
my husband
works out of town two weeks on two weeks
off okay
how long has he done that for 13 years
okay so for most of his life yeah
and so i i mean
he i don't know if it's just that
he always acts like he's an adult even
though he's not an adult like he
he views himself as like our equal
um do you treat him like he's your equal
or let me say it this way do you
do you use him as a friend when your
husband's gone
do you use him as quote unquote the man
of the house the
um the guy who picks up the slack when
dad's gone has he been put
into a grown-up role
that's a good question um i mean i'll
have him
do more of the physical jobs that need
to be done sure
because i do need the help yeah less
than less those
is there a sense that he is and this
isn't necessarily a bad thing so don't
hear me blaming i'm just trying to get
some information
right right but is is he
viewed in that role all right you're the
man of the house while i'm gone i need
you to really step up
hey there's somebody knocking on the
door i need you to go take care of that
you take care of your brothers and
sisters
you're the only guy around here so you
got to deal with the
you know i don't know the snowmobile
okay so where did
he get this where does he get that sense
from
um i'm really not sure
he just kind of always had the the
personality of
of that i mean he's always been
tucked back um
i'm not sure so i'm sure that's not any
help well that's it's good info
so um what what have you tried over the
years to curb his
his stealing um we've tried
talking to him we've tried making him
you know buy the thing that he destroyed
and
give it back to the person
we've tried taking away privileges
but with the privileges it's always like
oh that doesn't matter that doesn't
that doesn't affect me i'll just i'll
just do something else
okay yeah
so but i i mean the only other thing i
can think of is like
i'm often i don't know i'm just often
stressed out because i've got
three other kids sure um and he causes a
lot of
stress yeah the stuff that he's doing
so i don't know if it's just maybe the
stress
and that he knows that we're unhappy
with him and so he's just
doing more of it um i'm gonna ask you
something crazy when's the last time
just you and him went out
and i haven't you looked at him in the
eye and said hey tell me about what's
going on in your world you got any
girlfriends
all right how's school doing
i don't i haven't gone out with him much
one-on-one
he did go out with his dad um and they
went
camping and he was just like he was
great he didn't have any
issues there was no problems he wasn't
disrespectful
okay yeah so
what you've done restitution grounding
him
um making him pay double
right the next move is like physical
right it just escalates in those ways
sometimes kids respond to that
often they don't right and so yeah
yeah i may be way out to lunch here
two things one there's something you're
not telling me and that's okay
there is some sort of tension in that
home
that he is absorbing and whether that's
13 years of two weeks on two weeks off
or of just the chaos of having two is he
got two
younger siblings three three young so
there's four in the house
yeah okay whether that is he is
desperate for
money because um he's caught up in
things he shouldn't be caught up in
whatever that looks like
there's a disconnect between two things
one
his value in role his participation in
this home
okay he has had to take it upon himself
to be the big bad dude
and the big bad dude can do whatever the
big bad dude wants to do including take
stuff
i got money double it i don't care yeah
and or i'm just gonna take this from you
okay so right he sounds like somebody
who's a political
the other political party one they're
like yeah we'll show you right he just
sounds like that
right and yeah um the other thing is
is he is not see himself as a
participating member of this
family unit right okay so there's not a
common set of values that everybody's
buying into here
and i here's the thing i'm not getting
into
the he's got he's never felt the pain
of what happens when you are one of the
four pillars holding this house up and
you just you opt out and the house falls
over right he doesn't
that's he's disconnected from that he
doesn't feel the pain
of not participating right so he just
kind of can do whatever he wants to
my guess is i can't imagine
how loud and exhausting especially
when it gets dark for seasons i can't
imagine
anything other than if the 15 year old's
quiet
things are okay because the other three
are setting things on fire
right and then it becomes this feedback
loop
and he's not even going to think this
intentionally
of i am just floating out here i am
pluto i may not even be a planet anymore
and i'm going to circle back and whether
it's negative attention positive
attention
loud attention i'm bigger than the rules
i'm bigger than this family system i got
three more years till i'm out of here
i'm stuck out here and no one even cares
anyway which is a
15 year old saying hey somebody look at
me
right and i'm not saying to let him get
away with anything in fact the opposite
here's where i would start if i'm you
and i want to start with
i'll start with this it's me being
vulnerable as a kid
i was a awful thief
i stole baseball cards dude i was such a
punk i didn't break into
you know i wasn't like breaking into
stores or anything dude i was just a
jerk
i was a jerk and i don't think i was a
bad guy
right right now we could deconstruct my
whole life
that's not the point but i want to tell
you is this
he can and i think he will grow up i
think he can't man
you talk about i didn't get mad at my
students very often
but i grew to where i had no holds
barred for
theft because it was so divisive in
communities and i had to learn that and
had some people
be very candid with me right and really
i had to feel the weight of what happens
when
i become part of the reason a community
or a value system falls apart so here's
what i want you to do
number one i want you to find some child
care
and i want you to take him out on a date
just y'all too
okay and i want you to probably write
down some questions
and i want you to tell them it's gonna
be weird but we're going on a date just
me and you he's like oh mom
and you tell him no there is no
discussion
no nothing and i want you to start the
date by telling him
i haven't told you this in a long time
and i'm sorry
i absolutely am crazy about you and i
love you
and you are the big brother in this
house and i'm so glad you're the big
brother in this house i'm so glad you're
my first son
i'm so grateful for you and
i haven't asked you about your
girlfriends i haven't asked you about
sports i haven't asked you about schools
or robots or
what painting whatever he's into
and i want you to force him into a
conversation about himself
over a meal and then here's part two
and hey some of that is gonna be awkward
because this is new and he's gonna think
this is a setup
and uh you you can tell him hey listen
i can outwait you i dream of silent
moments and so i'll sit here silently
for this whole dinner and just stare at
your beautiful beautiful face
um okay but tell me what's going on and
you can tell them this
if you don't tell me about who you're
interested in i'm going to tell you
about how i fell in love with your dad
and how he used to make out on dates i
mean you can get them to talk right
right um the second part is
i want you to tell them that you are
going to create a value system for the
home
and it needs everybody's input so one of
the things we have at our house that
we got the kids involved with me and my
wife did is we sat down and got
everybody on the table
and we talked about not what the rules
are of the dolony house we don't hit we
don't steal
no we did something a little bit deeper
than that we talked about who the
delonies are
okay we are people who say yes we are
people of hospitality we always have
people
over at our house people trying to work
on their marriage people who are just
our friends people who are
goofy or silly or loud and vote
different than us we have a
cadre of wackadoos staying at our house
right we had a group of people tent out
in our front yard last night it was
awesome
and so we are always have people over we
are
people of adventure and then we get into
we are people who treat others with
respect
and dignity and so when my daughter
or my son hit somebody takes something
we always circle back to hey here's the
family values that we all
opted into and you chose to opt out
and man i love having you here
and i hate that you opted out here's the
consequences of that
right you are a part of this system and
we need you here and i see you
my son i see you i want you to start
touching him regularly and tell him
i'm going to touch your face every day
and i'm going to look in your eyes
because you're beautiful
and this is going to be so weird and i
want you to do it
and it's gonna help both of you and he's
gonna
freak out i also want you to tell him
there is no more theft in our home okay
there is nothing more divisive than
stealing in this house
and you will feel significant
consequences when that happens
okay i don't know what that looks like
in your house
but it has to be very strong not that
you're coming in as the warrior mom
but it's because he opted out of this
set of values that you all agreed on
right in our home or this if you can do
it in your husband's home too even
better
even awesome and i know this sounds
counterintuitive and there's going to be
people who get in the internets
and the comments and say you know what
he needs he needs a spanking
he needs to have all this and we're
taking it
this kid needs to feel like he's got
value
he needs to look like he is seen he
needs to understand that mom
loves loves loves him his brothers and
sisters
need him that his dad loves loves loves
him
and that a value in this home is you do
not steal
you do not take from those from anybody
ever and their response will be swift
it may be worth i'll tell you this my
dad my granddad was one of the nicest
men who ever lived
kind nice man and my dad took me down to
my granddad's house one day
and i had to go sit in the garage in
houston and talk to my granddad about
lying
i remember that conversation to this day
because my granddad looked at me an old
wise man and said deloney's don't lie
we tell the truth and i remember that
conversation to this day
and it may mean that you got to get
somebody at your local from your local
school or local community where you work
who has been to jail has had run-ins
with the law someone who can sit down
with your son
not in the scare them straight not that
kind of way but who can say hey man
as a society we've all said we don't
steal the more you opt into this man the
consequences are going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and
don't go to jail man you got money
i don't think the theft is because he
needs it for drugs i don't think the
theft is
because he needs it he's embarrassed i
think he's walking through life because
the rules don't apply to him
and i think he's walking through life
like he's bigger than the rules
that's cool i'll just take it it's fun
and he's got to get plugged into a
system that counts on him
and what i'll tell you crystal is that
changed me
that changed me those hard conversations
changed me those value plugins changed
me
and a group of people that held me
accountable really uncomfortably so
changed me thank you so so much for that
call hey listen
um i i get this email a lot so
i want to take a minute here i get an
email about how to find a therapist
i get email a lot um what makes a good
therapist i've been in therapy and it's
stupid
it's dumb here's a good email from
allison she writes
i've been seeing a therapist since march
of 2020
i don't know if she's making an impact
on my life as of today
i feel like i'm paying for a chat with a
girlfriend yikes
what makes a good therapist are there
specific things that should be going on
during a typical session all right so
i'm gonna back that out and here's a
couple of things here
number one well let's just answer the
directly a good therapist
is not your friend they are not your
friend
they are a teacher they are someone who
is walking alongside you right
so a therapist is not your friend they
should not be
be condescending or unrelatable and they
should rarely
rarely give you advice that's not their
job
their job is to hold a mirror up their
job is to say
you say this but here's how you're
living you want to be free but here's
how you spend your money
you want to have great relationships
here's how you choose to fill in the
blank right
their job is to listen deeply to reflect
to teach you how to connect the dots
across relationships and events
and consequences a therapist is not a
mystic
or a healer or predictor of the future
right
as i said earlier a therapist is not
your friend
they're not your buddy they're not your
future romantic partner they're not
someone to try to win over
they're someone to be honest with right
their job is to teach you how to be a
good friend or
how to be a good romantic partner
i started seeing a counselor recently uh
here in nashville
and within 45 minutes man i thought we
were gonna get in a fist fight
he said some things like hey here's what
you've told me about xyz
and i looked at him and thought you
better not say that again
and then he smiled and said ah what is
that
is that sadness or anger and i was like
ooh you got me well played well
played homie and we had a good exchange
he's not my friend
right he's just simply reflecting back
to me things that i was saying that i
hadn't put the dots together on and i
put together dots for a living right
a good therapist a good therapist will
challenge you
therapy should be uncomfortable if it's
done right
a counselor should not always be neutral
they should tell you the truth when
you're wrong
that's been a big thing in the
counseling profession you know
never take sides i think that's nonsense
man i really side with terry reel on
this one
sometimes you got to take sides
sometimes you got to look at someone and
say this behavior is childish
this behavior is hurting the people you
love this behavior is
not getting you what you said you wanted
to get right it's their job to point you
in a new direction you haven't
considered or
challenges you're avoiding right and as
i've said throughout this
little rant here a good therapist
reflects you to yourself
they hold up a mirror they show you how
people experience you
in the world right so here's a good
example
session two session three the counselor
might find themselves getting really
bored
a good counselor will lean in and be
bold and say the people in your world
call you boring do they experience you
as
eeyore as kind of slow um
as like do they
often check their watch or their phone
when you're talking what they
are teaching you is here is how the
world experiences you
right when the therapist feels bored it
might sound harsh right but
when they reflect their experience and
shares the truth gently it's one of the
most loving things they can do for you
because we live in a culture where
people don't tell the truth or when they
do they weaponize it
and they don't say hey i'm struggling to
stay connected with you is this how
other people experience you
have people told you that before no in
the real world they say
girl you're bored you don't want to hang
out or they lie to you as
to why they don't invite you to things
right if you truly want to develop
skills of connection you got to be able
to accept this honest feedback right
so that's what a therapist does and so
no if you've been allison if you've been
in therapy since march 2020 and your
therapist
isn't challenging you to work towards
goals that you've established
if they aren't challenging you to see
the world differently to develop new
skills to teach you new ways of
interacting with yourself and other
people
yeah man it's time for you to move on if
you leave counseling and think ah i'm
just chatting with my friend
man you are wasting 150 right or
whatever it costs
right 5 000 or 50 or whatever it happens
to be
and therapist don't do that
don't just take people's money there's
the backlogs are too big
there's too many people who need help if
people are doing well and you're just at
the chatting stage
let them go let them go if you
need to find a therapist ask people you
trust check with your insurance for an
in-network provider think about what
kind of therapist you're going to need
right
you can be more comfortable meeting with
a man or a woman do you want online
telehealth appointments or in person
i'm super biased about in person if at
all possible right
does it do they have to have spiritual
beliefs that you share or worldview
beliefs
does it need to be somebody who
specializes in grief or marriage or
parenting or aging trauma
whatever it is think about what you're
looking for ask people you trust
check with your insurance provider check
online
or look into local resources and there's
everything from
graduate school university programs i
was an intern
right that's and i saw people for free
i was at a family counseling that had
sliding scale for folks who couldn't
afford
high dollar stuff and then there's cash
pay right if you are blessed and you've
got the money and you can pay for cash
pay
go get it whatever you need to do and
then ask your potential therapist a few
questions do you accept my insurance
can you help me with my particular
challenges will we commit to this
relationship for a few months or for
longer and here's the big one
don't give up after the first session it
should be awkward and weird
right i left my first session the other
day fired up
and i can't wait to go back because i
know that challenge is good
it's like going to the gym and getting a
personal trainer and that first session
makes you sore the next day and you're
like i'm never working out again
no you're supposed to right if you
haven't been to the gym in a while it's
supposed to be uncomfortable
it's supposed to be right so if you are
struggling
and you need somebody please be bold and
brave and go
talk to somebody right go a couple of
sessions before you bail out
and for god's sakes man prepare to be
challenged
it's good it's good to be challenged
it's hard but it's good
all right let's go to james in chicago
james what's up how can i help
hey dr john how's it going good brother
how are you
i'm doing great good what's up man how
can i help
so my question is my wife and i we have
a
three-year-old in one room one-year-old
boy
and they're both embryo adoptions my
wife was able to carry them
but they really don't have anything to
do with us
so my question is hey hold on hold on
page hold on they have
everything to do with y'all okay i
i i do get that i just don't know i
guess the proper way to say i just want
to make sure i got my point across
okay yeah you got it you got it they're
not your
is it biological is it your sperm or is
it
is it fertilized eggs
neither of us okay gotcha okay
so you adopted fertilized embryos and
then you had
you got two kids there you go yes she
carried on boat
but we just got embryos from the
hospital
okay very cool so my question is
we we have every intention of telling
them but we need to know age-appropriate
maybe some
unique ways i've heard of maybe possible
books that help with that like kids
books even
sure so but we need help along the way
of when and how
and and not to make it seem awkward you
know yeah you betcha man thank you so
much for having that heart
good for you um you just told me the
ages and i missed him
three in one is that right that is
correct okay
so with your three-year-old and it
happens way quicker than you think it's
going to man
because it i was super caught off guard
they will begin
exploring their own bodies and
whatever words you guys use to decide to
call body parts and things right
one of those important goals for every
parent is to not make
any part of a human body feel weird
right or feel shameful or feel right and
so i'm backing way up i'm going to get
to your question here
for my grad students we used to make all
the grad students
had to say in unison right you have to
say vagina out loud you have to say
penis out if you can't say that you
can't be a therapist right you can't say
body parts
you can't be fair if you can't say body
parts you can't be a parent that should
be a rule
right and we've got generations of kids
who were ashamed of their body parts
right it led to all kinds of stuff so
that's number one
your three-year-old is probably already
there asking questions
they will become four and five and six
during this time
they're gonna ask natural questions
where do babies come from
where do i come from that's when you can
in an age-appropriate way
with all of the joy and miracle and
excitement you guys can muster
there are eggs inside of the girl body
right
and then they have sperm in the boy body
and they meet together
and then they make a baby and
we didn't even we weren't able to have
those in our bodies so we got some from
somebody
else and so we had to put it in our body
right so
it's very very natural they will not
carry the baggage that you guys
feel they'll just go huh oh
right and so think about this
when you were a kid well i don't know
how old how old are you
uh 39 30. okay sweet so you're 39 so
we're in the same boat here trying to
explain
to us when we were five what an ipad is
would have sounded like the jetsons
right my kids just it was there when
they were born
and the that idea that they're carrying
around this
half like three centimeter piece of
metal and glass that they can talk to
people on the other side of the world
and see their faces is not a they don't
carry that
almost every time i look at an ipad i'm
like this is insane
right so they won't carry that same
baggage
as they get older right seven eight nine
ten they will ask
deeper questions and that's when you can
be more open
about hey here's how mommy's body worked
here's how daddy's body's worked here's
some of the medical challenges we have
and here's what was so neat and like
another family
where it's willing to share you with us
and you're our
baby and you can show them where babies
come from and the pregnancy pictures and
all of
that miraculous stuff and it will be
like a
whoa as your kid gets to be 10 11
12 13 14 that's when they'll start
asking questions about
hey do you think my biological parents
exist right are they out there
do you have re do you have contact with
them do you know who they are
um we have like names and information
but they're
as of right now last we heard they
didn't want contacted or reached out to
so okay so what i expect what we've seen
over the last five to ten years james
and what i expected to accelerate is
with 23 and me
with um the internet basically
man there's br there's very few quote
unquote closed adoptions anymore
kids want to know where they're from and
they want to know who they're from
and now that we've got genetic stuff for
medical things they want to know
um what might i expect down the road
medically speak there's all kinds of
things there right
and so i would expect that and by you
time you get to those conversations
hopefully you will have an openness in
your house
a and a where your kids will come to you
for things
they know you will never shy away from a
hard conversation whether it's a body
part conversation or a sex conversation
or a
racism or politics conversation whatever
that looks like you are always going to
be a safe space
that honors them when they ask questions
right and
never makes them feel dumb then when you
get to that 12 and 13 14 and 15 and they
can
understand science a little bit more
when they can start to understand
heritage where am i from legacy those
kind of things
you can honestly and openly discuss that
with them
and if you don't feel comfortable there
are professional counselors who that's
their job
is to have those type of conversations
and bridge those gaps as you mentioned
there are some
great children's literature out there
you can just look at amazon
to find some great children's books up
you know that will walk through these
magical
it gives kids a picture in their mind so
they can see it and go
wow that's me right and
they it will make them feel a part of
something when they see somebody like
them in a book right that's why
like inclusion in children's literature
is so important when a kid can see
themself in a book and just feel like
that kid looks like me they have hair
like me they have
skin like me they have a face like me in
very much like your situation
right um they got to
take a ride and put into mommy's tummy
and mommy had a big big tummy and then
i was born just like right and they
become part of a narrative they can see
and experience
here's the other thing i don't ever ever
ever want you to ever
ever ever say anything other than i'm
your dad and your mom's your mom
is that cool yeah i don't
ever ever ever want you to feel anything
less than their mom or their dad because
you are
have you carried around stuff in your
heart for a while about that
yeah it's it's yeah kind of difficult
and
and here we're we're trying to have
another kid however
god seems deemed necessary if he does
and one thing we're going through we try
to get back in the same program they
told us it's not likely
and we've heard stories of people saying
you know after their wife's carried a
couple sometimes
things work out and you have your own
and so yeah
we're i think we're still kind of
dealing with that in some areas you know
we had an incident a couple months ago
where she kind of had some things that
she thought might have been a pregnancy
but it ended up being
something different so we were kind of
getting excited and you know
dealing with the whole it didn't happen
again type thing so i don't know it's
just
still some more in there james are
y'all staying connected through this
yeah
yeah we do pretty well okay here's what
i want to tell you
and i'm i'm i'm looking directly into
the camera here i know you can't see me
but
um i've been down this road and
me and my wife experienced the pain of
infertility the
challenges with those things very very
differently
and we both thought we were pretty close
and then come to find out whoa we were
experiencing these things
way way differently and
if you just went through yet another
loss and i'm not talking about loss of a
pregnancy i'm talking about loss of
hope right that begins to weigh on your
heart that weighs on her heart and it
just weighs differently
so i want you guys to make sure you are
hyper hyper proactive
about your relationship how you
communicate to one another how you love
one another
and how you give each other space to
grieve whatever that looks like for each
other
this can be a something that binds you
guys together
but it can be devastating for a couple
okay and i'm just talking i'm just
i've been there okay yeah and
most importantly if you want to set your
that
three-year-old beautiful baby and that
one-year-old little baby those
miracles which is what they are
they are what they could what they have
done was it's just unfathomable
oh yeah for sure listen those are your
kids
right and the best thing you can do for
those kids is be
intertwined and connected to the with at
the soul level
with their mom okay
yeah that's number one number two is
never think of yourself any less
they're not a step away from you they
are every bit of part of your soul
brother
and you did a brave brave bold thing
by going through the adoption process by
going through
the embryo adoption process which comes
which comes with risk
and it comes with hope and there's
nothing more intoxicating in this in the
this this season than hope and there's
nothing more devastating
than hope right you are their dad
they are your kids and they will be
forever
and your wife is a mom she carried him
to term
she's got two little babies and they are
your kids
you're a dad brother let that sink in
put all that shame
all that hey yeah but but there is no
butts your dad my man
and start today creating a home where
your kids feelings count where their
questions count
where they see you and your wife having
hard conversations together
they see you all hugging together they
see y'all dealing with hard things
together
model those conversations and then
you're going to create kids that when
the hard conversations come and they
will
that's part of it they're not going to
go running the hills not going to run to
the internet they're going to go running
to the two
safest people they know in the world
that's james that's you and your wife
i love your heart brother thank you so
so much man all right so as we wrap up
today's show
um
man i don't know if i can make it
through this song today i'm just going
to cut to it
this is uh a magic song that i hold
close to my heart
and has been for a long long time from
edie brickell
the new bohemians from years ago
for off the album shooting rubber band
at the stars it's called circle
it says me i'm a part of a circle of
friends
and we we notice you don't come around
and me i think it all depends on you
touching ground with us
but i quit i give up nothing's good
enough for anybody else it seems
and i quit i give up nothing's good
enough for anybody else
and being alone is the best way to be
when i'm by myself it's the best way to
be
when i'm all alone it's the best way to
be and when i'm by myself
nobody else can say goodbye everything
is temporary anyway when the streets are
wet and the colors slip into the sky but
i don't know why that means you and i
are that means you and i quit i give up
and me i'm a part of your circle of
friends and we notice you don't come
around
if you've got friends in your life hug
them close
everything is temporary hug them close
this is the dr john delaney show
[Music]